[Music]
hello thank you so much for for having
the year
I'm incredibly intimidated but I will
try to get through it a little bit about
me my name is Ivana I work at a company
called customer i/o we're based in
Portland but it's a remote company so I
live in work in Vancouver in Canada I
was born in Bosnia though raised in
Croatia lived all over Canada and then
spent several years in Scotland most
recently I have a degree in psychology
and neuroscience but realized too late
that I didn't want to be an academic and
right now I'm a UX designer but have
worked as an interaction designer a
freelancer and front-end designer and
I've had the pleasure of CSS being
involved in all of those things so over
time and across countries I've made lots
of internet friends and real-life
friends and as a result I've always been
really into how we build our communities
on the web both socially and from a code
perspective as well and how those things
interact so now that you know a little
bit about me I want to ask you guys what
do you do um what do you call yourself
we don't often describe our roles in one
word because we know that there's
usually not one succinct title for them
we contextualize those job titles with
the technologies and the languages that
we work with but have no real common
language for these things front-end
engineer for example might mean
something really different to me than it
does to you someone saying they're a
software developer doesn't tell you
initially a lot about what they built or
what they used to build it but we
simplify right we contextualize and
categorize because that behavior makes
our lives easier it makes the world
easier to compute
but this category categorization excuse
me can harm our communities too because
how we categorize is based on what we
value and how we talk about our
profession about CSS that that matters
and that's what I want to talk about so
to do that we have to go back to to the
beginning we have to rewind a little bit
um it did start this way right like CSS
fit very easily into that kind of design
appearance bucket there's a clear
separation between design and
development you had a web designer and
now you kind of have designer and
developer like with visuals being one
thing and code another and you can sort
of see these lines building but the web
is growing in so many ways right and you
know not a day goes by that we don't see
a piece on medium and I'm pretty sure
written a few on how designers and
developers can work together best and
the reason we do that is because the
lines between them have blurred so much
that we don't even know what makes a
designer and what makes a developer
because the web isn't just a screen we
don't build a website we build an
application builds interfaces across
devices and contexts and interactions
are more dynamic these experiences are
more immersive and this needs how much
for wider variety of skill sets and I
think this is awesome right because as
the industry grows and so do our
capabilities so do our roles and our
skills we can generalize or even
specialize we can focus on CSS is a
whole or just on one small aspect of it
and this is really cool we talked a lot
about how we should work together how we
can make development and design work
together where CSS fits into that and
where we fit into that and yet yeah
we may not see this like outright of
course or maybe we do I've heard it but
the implication is always there it's
there when we ask what front end means
or doesn't mean it's there when we ask
you know which coding language should I
learn next and it's in job postings it's
in salaries it's in the word development
CSS used to just be designed so what is
it now this is an issue without a
resolution and that lack of resolution
has consequences we have so much
fluidity in our roles and that's okay
and but we need to produce software at
the end of the day and the titles that
we hold matter because they impact so
much hiring team construction perception
pay not to mention the actual experience
of what it is we're building and so no
it's not so much about developer and
designer because we don't build web
pages now the above simply isn't the
case anymore
it's not just fonts and colors and CSS
is code but not development why we say
that language is like HTML and CSS are
about presentation whereas programming
is meant to development is meant to
describe function and this was very
convenient but CSS has grown a lot right
we have pre-processors that require
developers level of understanding just
to implement and use meaningfully like
like if you looked at some of the docs
for these things it's like for a
beginner trying to walk or beginner
through some of it it's okay I just fire
up a terminal and install this and all
of these dependencies and no but that's
not development right anyway we have
transforms right we have complex
targeted selectors like pseudo elements
right and if you think about that name
for a second it kind of blows my mind a
little bit like pseudo
like it doesn't actually fists like
dynamically populated and with
methodologies like object-oriented CSS
CSS layout now and the point of all this
isn't is to show that it's not just
presentation and function the code might
looks really simple and people might say
oh it's just CSS but interaction and
presentation effects function and they
enable function CSS bridges all of that
it touches everything and expert level
CSS is a key development skill and these
days like was mentioned in the intro
people are showing off which you can do
with CSS and you can say that this is
just design right just aesthetics but
that that's missing the point the
implications of being able to do things
like this and just CSS was crazy
a while ago whole games can be built in
it I believe later today we're going to
learn how to do that and this is an
example of something that a friend of
mine created thanks Q it's a CSS
framework but it's made up of
self-contained modules and it's
developed in a way that draws from
JavaScript and from Ruby dependencies
are managed important serve specified
and because of its modularity the CSS
can actually be tested and also last
night at the speaker drink several sort
of folks who work primarily with
JavaScript said to me like I don't do
CSS CSS is hard like Rachel one of my
fellow speakers said like the most
complicated stuff I do with CSS but that
other more quote-unquote developer tasks
have more legitimacy with attached to
them and even if you you know do
subscribe to the whole like CSS is just
presentation fine as I mentioned
presentation influences the way that
people feel about software it enables
successful interaction if something
isn't presented and can be interacted
with in the right way
its function is irrelevant there need to
be people who stand that this or who
code I suppose at this intersection of
interaction function and presentation
and because of how complex the web is
they deserve their place in development
and that brings me to the main point
nice and my talk we're struggling to
delineate design and development in
terms of language to give those things
value and find out where we fit while
struggling with sort of bias and
archetypes and what happens when these
definitions of development and CSS are
unclear unspoken
and like tied up in these complex
perceptions of ourselves and our
competencies so hierarchies are about
drawing lines they're about identifying
differences and similarities and then
and this is the important part of
hierarchies assigning them rankings
assigning them relative importance this
lets us categorize and compare things
relatively speaking
things like languages the languages you
speak to organized in hierarchies or
colors evolutionary trees but the kind
of hierarchies that I'm talking about
here are value based on power and
authority in a CSS context and in
general we draw them because we like to
know that we have a place in society
within our communities we like to know
where we stand in relation to our others
were happy when we identify with a group
like a sports team or fans of a CSS CSS
framework for example and we're also
happy when we don't identify with
another group this is social identity
theory we define categories and then we
compare and you know right here were
here because we value CSS and identify
positively with those who have that
skill this conference wouldn't exist
otherwise and on some level these things
are good
like I said they help us process the
world faster and understand how to
interact socially it helped us they
helped us be less overwhelmed by the
world
they help employers apply people to the
right jobs somewhat and when we're in
those jobs they help us get our work
done and if we need help it lets us know
who to go to but they can also be bad
for the relative importance reasons that
I mentioned earlier and who defines that
importance so let's think about why for
a second
who defines this like if I ask you to
put some things in the development there
and the other things in not development
like where would you put them and what
about the person next to you or your
coworker I would venture to say that
those things wouldn't all be the same
and the fact that they wouldn't be is
something is what I want to address
because if you're hiring someone you
need to decide how much to pay them how
do you how do you do that what do you
decide first like do you decide the
technology stack of the the job maybe
the experience but we don't even know
what that means for a given language
especially if it hasn't been around that
long
so we're categorizing and determining
someone's value before they even exist
and these hierarchies that we have in
our minds you know the hiring manager
the engineers this person that will be
working with the designers up there
working with these all differ in subtle
ways and these ways then compound and
this impacts who you hire a CSS
developer for example might be what you
need but if you don't identify that as a
valued development thing you won't hire
that person and this is something that I
found interesting
astac overflows developer surveys they
didn't include CSS as a language like
anywhere but at least they're open about
it
and I think that the only valuable
hierarchies are clear transparent ones
and it's this lack of transparency
that's the problem we're not drawing
these hierarchies between skill levels
like manager and junior that's its own
thing but across languages we're
building tacit value-based hierarchies
based on languages that are biased by
our own investments
like of course I'm going to value CSS
higher than amber or whatever because
I've invested time and money into
learning it and I love it but I can't
assume that the person next to me feels
the same or if even that's what my
product needs so what's the point um why
are we trying to understand trying so
hard to understand what makes a
developer anyway because we need to were
compelled to in order to make our world
easier to understand but also because
these hierarchies affect CSS the
language the community and the web and
Tec is changing so fast that we have no
like agreed-upon standard for what a
developer is there's no degree or
certification or whatever and we pride
ourselves on that like anyone can jump
in and get their start in it I learned
development on like Neopets for like
anyone remembers that but it's a
double-edged sword because at the same
time we're trying to make sense of how
to pay people how to hire us and how to
actually make software and knowing that
we haven't figured that out is fine but
I'd argue that the way we're going about
it this implicit value building based on
like outdated assumptions about CSS
that's wrong because there's a gravitas
to the word developer like a technical
proficiency tied up with credibility
that for some reason CSS just doesn't
get and instead of critiquing that
Association like we're worrying about
where to draw these lines and the
problem again isn't that these
hierarchies necessarily exist but that
they subtle
there's the differ subtly based on the
company the person the job post and then
those reading that information are left
trying to infer these these categories
these hierarchies and because we're not
clear we we're not clear on the
hierarchies we stripped them of their
effectiveness if we don't come to the
table with a shared understanding of
development and how CSS is a part of it
we can't clearly communicate what we
value
and true hierarchies good hierarchies
are clear they're unambiguous and if not
we leave the door open for changing
interpretations of value and we leave
the door open for bias and intact this
automatically skews in favor of a
certain archetype and I'll talk more
about that in a minute
like I mentioned this might be a joke
right but its repetition is damaging
because it becomes implicit it becomes
an assumption that we make going in and
don't question anymore and to be clear
I'm not saying that there isn't a
difference between like CSS HTML
Javascript and languages like C like I'm
not saying it's not a difference
but what's dangerous is the power
dynamics and subtle implications that
one is harder and therefore better than
the other and the creation of archetypes
around them this becomes ingrained it
leads us to make bad decisions and treat
others poorly in some cases even when we
don't mean to in the same way that
characterization makes it easier to
place people in roles it also makes it
easier to devalue people and saying you
know CSS isn't really development or
some variant of that takes away from
what I think is a thriving debate around
where CSS is going and what it's capable
of you know for the more we don't talk
about it if I don't know how your
hierarchy differs from mine we'll never
come to any sort of consensus and this
is implicit but the problems manifest
explicitly and the developer archetype
and you know what he looks like
generally is how this implicit weird
value-based programming language
hierarchy intersects with a biased
social one this this developer male
usually sits implicitly at the top of
the hierarchy and yes it doesn't write
CSS and illustrate how this intersection
becomes complicated think about how it
might manifest when sort of a white male
quote unquote CSS developer
and you know a female perhaps
quote-unquote CSS developer of color
applied for the same job
what hierarchies are applied to those
people when we don't know or we aren't
transparent about it we reach you know
we reach into our subconscious for
things we do quote-unquote know and then
when that knowledge is already wrong
that of a particular archetype being a
developer and good at computer things we
shoot ourselves in the foot it means
that we compromise CSS the people who
use it and develop in it and we
compromise the industry by leaving out
people that can actually impact it the
most and furthermore if you know we're
sitting at that hiring table and we
don't hire any CSS developer at all
because we don't value CSS as a
development skill it impacts the web a
bit more so just a couple of examples
here and I think this point it needs
belaboring because it intersects with
how CSS perception interacts with the
social and prevents people who end up
you know lower in these hierarchies
through no fault of their own from
participating in our community and
contributing to CSS development and then
CSS development contributing to the web
as a whole and this is complicated
there's so many hierarchy here and what
group what we group which fruits we
arbitrarily assigned to sort of high and
low status but we just kind of accepted
this and we've done very little to
change it and beyond beyond that beyond
archetypes and social intersections um
whether or not CSS is defined as
development has impacts on how people
see our skill as technicians and as
builders of the web for example Jess
calm you has about twice as many
attendees as this conference and
attracts about five times the sponsor
support and of course a lot goes into
that that data but it's experience sort
of suggests that recruiting and
conference budgets related CSS are much
smaller compared to what's spent on
JavaScript so
you know if you develop CSS but don't
know amber or something equivalent or
are you more skilled or valuable or less
why and who says are you worth more
money you're more credibility when we
perceive people as more skilled we give
those people power and these power
dynamics are tied up with assumptions of
legitimacy and until now it's been the
assumptions of people in power people
with privilege that govern these
perceptions like we want to say that
legitimacy development legitimacy is a
meritocracy but it's not and we know
it's not there are implicit valid ways
to be a developer and CSS isn't yet seen
as one of them and I believe that it
should be this perception of developer
legitimacy is really important for
minority groups for the underrepresented
as well because these implicit
structures as I mentioned take power
away from those who should have it and
prevent them from contributing to
development to the web to the
experiences that we're building on it
and in the office context perhaps people
are excluded from meetings or cold
reviews based on perceived language
value and expertise and their inputs
lost if they were even invited to begin
with one path into development isn't
better or more deserving than another
and this then leads to arbitrary pay
scales if I think development is worth a
lot of money but CSS isn't real
development then stands to reason that
CSS isn't worth as much money and and
then if the person doing that CSS
development is a member of our minority
group will pay them even less this is
the problem again and if our attitudes
and language based hierarchies become
value-based and vary from person to
person this negatively impacts
individuals communities and the forward
momentum of languages and CSS especially
and this has consequences on our mental
health because you know when you see
someone as less valuable
even in something as simple as which
language they choose to code in you will
behave differently towards them and just
because you see it as a joke doesn't
mean that someone else does for example
a front-end designer who works with CSS
every day might be as I mentioned
excluded from a meeting on a piece of
critical functionality because they're
not a developer and this has
consequences for them personally
professionally and not to mention for
the product they're building or the
site's they're building so and that
brings me to you know when these
applications are built a devaluing of
CSS in fact sent to when we give this
value across languages we don't bring
all the developers that we need this is
also from the stack overflow survey you
can just see these fluctuations in
popularity and popularity means most
commonly used and there's also yeah
there's wanted as well so look I'm not
taking issue with any of this and I'm
really happy that Sakura for do stuff
like this um but should the standing of
a particular language here influence how
people see our competency probably not
but for CSS it does so this yesterday on
my way to on my way here actually yeah
no yes when we as a community devalue
CSS into Deb skill you excellent
performance suffer and this is true when
we when we devalue CSS in Deb skill when
we don't challenge these hierarchies the
web suffers as do its users and as the
accessible enters into its own sub
disciplines and specialties you know we
have to be aware of our own hierarchies
as well and how that affects our own
community and how we can best mitigate
that so what can we do then I'm not
suggesting that we get rid of this or
tried to get rid of this like
fundamental human behavior because
hierarchies are fine they make us feel
safe but they need to be transparent and
forceful and concrete and not based
across languages we should feel
comfortable challenging them there are
differences between languages but we can
identify and understand those
differences and usually use them to
bridge skill gaps and solve problems
so if something is implicit right we
can't fight it if we don't know we
disagree or we're afraid to admit it we
can't make things any better so
individually organizationally we can ask
ourselves what our hierarchies are we
can write we can write down or somehow
record what we perceive to be a
developer and don't just ask the
question answer it and answer it openly
if we're scared of people having more
information it's a good sign that we're
doing something wrong we can be hyper
aware of our own biases and hierarchies
and be honest with each other
check assumptions not just at the door
but throughout and call each other on
them write them down before we talk for
example in a hiring meeting what's
important to everybody in the room don't
we shouldn't assume that we know and if
the hierarchies are so obvious if CSS
isn't really development then it should
be easy to state them saying them out
loud makes them real it bring it
surfaces those assumptions that are
empowering legitimacy and it takes them
away too it makes us accountable to our
definitions and we can't expect people
who are the victims of these hierarchies
to drive the change so those who of
hiring power can get across so as the
skill that those would hire in Paris
who's we can get across to people that
we value the skill that they bring not
the language of that skill manifest in
if we can if we can shout about CSS as
development we can and we should focus
on the skill sets that people are
bringing to us and start you know
getting a handle on those complex sensor
intersections that I mentioned and
challenging hierarchies in a broad
context means putting on early groups
and decision making roles and
challenging hierarchies by deviating
from them in a CSS context understanding
that CSS is technical is development
governs function and not just
presentation and it should be valued
like the complex skill set that it is if
it was and even if it wasn't real
development before it is now so let's
talk about that let's change
and know this isn't easy this is quite I
know he said that I would tell you tell
you what you know seasons development
and how to fix this but I I know that we
need to categorize we all know this and
I'm not asking you not to what I am
proposing here is this conversation that
those of us who think these hierarchies
are so obvious actually take a good look
at them document them and make them open
you know no shouting about right or
wrong or anything just openness and only
then once we have that transparency
around whether whether and who believed
CSS is development can we drive
meaningful change in one direction or
another
yeah so it's not easy but so what right
it's fine to be uncomfortable with
disagreement what's not fine is allowing
these mr. Bester because we're avoiding
having our opinions challenged we don't
have to agree but we have to come to
some sort of shared understanding like
why is it okay to use disagreement for
example in in the startup world in the
tech world to improve CSS or any other
language for that matter as cold but not
to improve the environment to the people
who write it in that language in these
interpersonal situations is hard to
admit perhaps that we've hurt someone
else or hurt an application to the thing
that we were building in some way
especially if we're asking with good
intentions but it's okay to make a
mistake right and
I don't think this is optional we pride
ourselves on solving hard problems and
can solve this we can drive CSS forward
as development and make what we're
building better and make our community
better we could put our money where our
mouths are and learn from failure like
we say we do all the time and if we said
CSS isn't real development in the in the
past it's fine we can always change the
hierarchies and better understand the
relationships of CSS to the rest of the
web and for us like CSS is just it's
just a start
it is development and let's make that
forgiving we can if we do that or if we
sort of set on the path to doing that we
could better understand our roles we can
actually leverage hierarchies the way
we're supposed to do right better
understand our roles as CSS engineers
developers designers whatever when we
better know what we value and how we can
know where to spend all of our energies
and how to put together better teams how
to make better products and better web
experiences and most importantly we can
make sure that our community is as
brilliant as we know it can be both
technically and otherwise thank you very
much for having me I appreciate it all
right
[Music]
oh that's fantastic